it's time now for CBS morning's deals
where we share items that might help
make your day a little bit better all at
exclusive discounts it's the second of
three days for CBS deals this week and
today we're featuring four products that
are all made in the USA USA so to start
shopping now scan the QR code on your
screen or visit cbsdeals.com lifestyle
host Gail bass joins us now good morning
good morning everybody first thing I
want you to do is to dig in because the
first device made in the
yeah I want to tell you about turbo
trusses but I love
so nice but what you put on them is
important oh yes that's what people are
going to remember and this has been
prepared with the turbo trusser now if
you saw shark tank you saw these guys
dressed as chicken and chicken in a
turkey and this is the device you'd
think you did you didn't know you needed
in your kitchen you put the it's so easy
to use I have video of me using this I
did it in 20 seconds where you tuck the
legs in there you hook the wings and
boom you're done there you can see all
right
it promotes even cooking and that breast
is nice and juicy I didn't need the
Schmaltz at the end just ate it right
off the bone Listen to vlads
[Applause]
I like a good restaurant
but this chicken is incredibly well
spiced yes what's going on all right
we're continuing this food story with
kyvin Foods because Reggie Kelly a
former NFL player was on the show
talking about these Gail you love the
sausages uh Becky our producer she
really really loves the honey apple
salsa but he makes wonderful barbecue
sauces this is Cherry Apple I'm doing
the Cherry apple is my favorite it's so
delicious just dig in and taste it and
what's really good is these are non-GMO
they're low calorie and if you can't
cook everybody will think you can if you
just pour this on everything and
everybody's like oh girl how'd you
season it you just tell them Hey Kevin
did it and he was looking for players
after the game right that's how he
started he was doing he was doing
football clinics and it was cooking and
he getting his wife decide you know what
let's do a small business and what's
really good is these are small batch
small Kettle batches
so yeah so he's a southern boy he's a
Southern Southern yeah and he's like you
do this with love and with taste you
don't want people to go home saying you
know that meat was a little oh this
sauce is amazing so you got juicy here
and you've got delicious here we're
selling these in bundles you want that
you'll want the MVP kit though I like
that okay that's what comes with the
honey salsa so I was just it comes the
salsa it's amazing yeah it's honey apple
salsa what's really good is that it
comes in it yeah that is definitely his
and it comes in mild and hot I'm from
the southwest so it's got to be hot it's
got to be hot what's the price range I
love the price range on this this starts
at 22.49 and remember we have these in
bundles so think about seasonings salsa
sauces hot sauce you get a kit
combination just go to cbsdeals.com and
you can pick what you love all right
Gail the other thing that it drives me
crazy especially in the summer is I buy
a lot of fruit and with within like
three days if you don't eat it it's gone
look at how old these strawberries
nothing I hate more than moldy
strawberries yes detmire green boxes are
one of our best
sometimes I just eat around them Gail
yeah
these green hey I just cut it around the
mold yeah exactly but Deb Mike wait wait
wait wait do you really do that are you
being serious yes I cut you cut the
little moldy part off you can't do that
yeah
you're gonna tell me you eat around the
moldy cheese too yeah well I'm French
okay he buys it moldy this is what you
do when you get green boxes you put your
veggies in there you wash them you put
them in and they extend the life of your
vegetables and your snacks and your
bread rolls that's why they're such a
good seller because people know that you
pay a lot of money for your fruits and
vegetables you want to extend the life
you go to a farmer market and you're
thinking well I don't want to buy all
that I'm going to waste it you're not
like the other day we featured s'mores
yesterday when me and boyfriend having
the date night with the bonfires that
you could get on cbsdeals.com you can
put them in there to save them for the
next day this is a great must-have and
we have the 16 piece set that 16 set
that's 32 pieces 16 16 pieces here for
how much 18 18. that is wow under twenty
dollars lastly you got something that
helps
okay I won't be slipping in the shower
yeah you know after you've had all that
barbecue you get dirty you need to jump
in the shower okay so you eat at your
dinner table
the these are wonderful if you want to
make sure that the people you care for
don't slip in the shower you know how
Surfers stay on their surfboards because
of the Kahuna grip these were developed
for Surfers so they don't slip and fall
so you put these in your bathroom and
use these These are either less than a
millimeter less than a millimeter thick
and we have these how much 50 uh 15.99
15.99
let's see how easy that is I did it with
one hand all right yes we love having
you of course we partner with all these
companies to get these deals to buy
anything you saw today scan that QR code
on your screen or head to cbsdeals.com
start shopping